stars are a pervasive form of power in
the lands between they comprise a big
part of ronnie's ending they connect
sorcerers to magical power they are
likely where most outer gods reside and
they are the source of quite a few of
the game's bosses we saw one star sent
alien in my discussion of the elden
beast and today i want to look at its
connection to another creature of the
stars the equally mysterious estelle
natural born of the void
we previously learned that the elden
beast is a being sent to the lands
between by the greater will it came on a
golden star it was set up as a defense
for the elden ring to ensure that it
operated according to the greater will's
desires with that foundation we can turn
our attention to estelle to
cross-reference for any connection and
as we delve into this new lore feel free
to subscribe to the channel to keep up
to date with all of my lore and elden
ring content
as for any notable boss a great starting
point to look at is its remembrance the
remembrance of the natural born tells us
that estelle is a malformed star born in
the flightless void far away once
destroyed an eternal city and took away
their sky a falling star of ill omen
more than a whole video could be
dedicated to deciphering this and the
rest of estelle's story so for the
purposes of this video i will be taking
the lead from v limits insightful
account i highly recommend you check out
his video on estelle so because estelle
destroyed an eternal city it could be
assumed that they were on the side of
the greater will and eldon beast perhaps
just another star sent to enforce the
greater will's plans after all the knox
which inhabit the eternal cities had in
the past invoked the ire of the greater
will and were banished deep underground
with the inhabitants of the eternal
cities being enemies of the greater will
enemies who went so far as to fashion
the finger slayer blade to kill its
vassal two fingers it is easy to think
that estelle would be on the greater
wills side by being seen as an enemy of
the nox but v-limit illustrates that
this might not be the case
if we look at the description of
estelle's remembrance closely we will
see that the two named eternal cities
nocron and noxtella don't quite fit the
description of having been destroyed and
robbed of their sky
both of the cities have many
non-destroyed architecture as well as
star-filled skies the skies are noted to
be false but they're still there in
contrast there is one more eternal city
which is more properly destroyed and
devoid of sky in the deep root depths
there is a grace that reveals the area
to be that of a forgotten nameless
eternal city now we only have reference
of the greater will banishing the nox
not destroying them or their cities this
led v-limit to posit that estelle might
have been created or harnessed by the
nox as a means of attack against the
greater will only to have their creature
turn against them level their city and
steal their sky
this would track with the fact that
despite there being two estelle the
natural born of the void at the end of
ronnie's quest and the stars of darkness
in the consecrated snowfield only one of
them has a night sky in their boss fight
arena the natural born has a star-filled
night sky just like those of the eternal
cities whereas the stars of darkness
introduces no unique atmosphere or sky
if only one sky were stolen as it seems
to be the case since only one eternal
city is missing a sky then we would only
expect to see one sky bearing estelle if
the greater will had sicked estelle onto
the nox and eternal cities i would think
that multiple estelle would mean
multiple cities destroyed and multiple
skies taken but that doesn't happen
if instead the estelle were some product
of a noxian plan then the single city
destruction could make sense if the knox
were only attempting that plan in one
city we know from their other creations
such as the mimic tears and the finger
slayer blade that the knocks were open
to trying anything and everything in
their aims of fighting back against the
greater will so making a few estelle
could seem plausible
so maybe the estelle are not an arm of
the greater will and instead a creation
of the knox if this is the case how did
the knox bring them about the greater
will could have just sent them in from
space like it does the elden beast at
least that's all the description we get
the nox not being outer gods likely
would have needed some specific method
to do this we might be able to learn of
these means by looking at what seems to
be another form of estelle that is the
falling star beasts the falling star
beasts are found in meteor impacts
throughout the lands between because of
their similar pincers gravity magic a
similar-looking growth in the case of
the full-grown falling star beast and
the fact that the natural-born's
remembrance explicitly calls estelle a
falling star the connections between
these two kinds of beings are undeniable
estelle are some derivative offshoot
evolution or some other form of the
falling star beasts b limit thinks that
the nox formed estelle out of the
falling star beasts giving them their
human-like influence the arms and skull
and i think this or something like it is
plausible
looking at the more prominent of the two
estelle's epithet a natural born or a
natural child is a euphemism for an
illegitimate child or a bastard the
remembrance can also be formed into a
weapon called the bastard's stars which
reads
formed of the same many-colored star
debris that comprise the form of the
natural born of the void
these themes speak to the fact that
estelle's birth or creation was in some
way unnatural or improper estelle was
born in the wrong way though in what
manner this birth is wrong is hard to
say for certain a right birth is likely
what the falling star beasts count as so
the most plausible explanation to me
would be that the knock somehow
interfered with some of the falling star
beasts likely when they were still stars
in space or first coming upon the lands
between
somehow the nox influenced or corrupted
the falling stars they had influence
over and turned them into what became a
stell
as v-limit points out if the nox wanted
something to contend with the greater
will and its star of the elden beast
what better than another star
and if we look at the two fights we come
to see a few threads of connection
despite their apparent dissimilarities
both of the fights take place in large
circular arenas both of the bosses have
some flavor of snake or serpentine
bodies and motion while many of their
attacks are different they both have a
painful grab and a star-like nebula
attack where they emit a cluster of
stars which then explode on a delay the
clusters do appear a bit different in
line with the different themes of each
boss estelle's is more purple and silver
the elden beast's is more red and gold
the silver of the nox against the gold
of the order
again taking an idea from v limit
seriously go watch his video
the experience one goes through in each
fight also share similarities as the
bosses bear a similar overall size and
rough shape attacking each one ends up
following like strategies the heads are
focal points to target but often end up
moving around enough to justify going
for appendages or body shots dodging
grabs and front-facing arm attacks is
contrasted with avoiding projectiles
raining down from the heavens in both
bites one could maybe say that the
similar fight experience and strategy is
due to the bosses being a similar type
and size and leave it alone there kind
of as a artifact of from soft just
making similar kinds of big bosses but
with the lore that fromsoft has written
in the game that connects these two a
deeper connection and rationale for the
similar fights is pretty hard to argue
with on a story perspective
as rival sources of star power estelle
and the elden beast seem well matched
something like two sides of a coin
though we do see more than one estelle
and there is a potential for even more
since there are so many falling star
beasts whereas the elden beast seems
more one of a kind
and as the singular envoy of the greater
will in addition to being the final boss
it does give it a bit more grandeur and
sense of power and scale
maybe the greater will has many more
beasts at its disposal like the many
seeming urgeries we see in the final
fights arena but in game we only see and
have evidence for the one if we really
want to speculate though the uniqueness
of estelle might be able to be defended
in some way if we take a step back and
remember that eldon ring is a game
filled to the brim with repurposed enemy
and boss assets for example there is
technically a lore justification for
them being different but in practicality
there are two godrics in the game one
got renamed to goad for and was given
just the teensy bit of story in the lore
to say they're different but in my
opinion the lore here seems very
derivative or after the fact of the
reusing of a story boss in an ever jail
it very well could have been the case
that estelle was a one of the kind who
then got the same treatment with a
sentence or two changed in the lore to
demarcate the natural born from the
stars of darkness and justify the reused
gameplay asset
we might be able to find justification
for this scene as estelle was one of the
most unique experiences in the game at
the culmination of ronnie's questline
only to lose its one-of-a-kind status to
a random boss repeat at the end of an
ice tunnel in a secondary optional area
in the game
though to not delve too far into a
critique of the game like the last video
we can't go further here without any
actual evidence from the game itself
which is something i don't think we have
the elden beast and estelle offer a
small kind of foil to one another
especially if they are in fact beasts of
opposing sides the greater will and the
knox unfortunately we don't have more
specific evidence to mull over to make
any further clear conclusions again in
like manner estelle is shrouded in
questions just as we saw with the elden
beast in a more dedicated exploration of
estelle and the stars the creatures from
the stars we might find a few more
answers about the nature of star
creatures and that could be a future
video on the channel but for now we have
seen the connection to the elden beast
despite a wealth of differences there
are a few threads that tie together
these otherworldly creatures if you
would like to join me in continuing this
journey through the lore and themes of
elden ring feel free to subscribe to the
channel or sign up to support me on
patreon where you get early access to
video scripts along with other perks in
addition to supporting the channel i
hope you've enjoyed watching and i'll
see you in the next video thanks bye